Speaker 1: Hey, I have to tell you, I know
that we don't we don't typically prefer
to take pleasure in others misfortune. But when
it comes to Newsmax, I'm taking pleasure. Newsmax
The radical right wing media network has had a
big shake up in terms of their on air talent,
as reported by Radar Online. Greg Kelly and Sean
Spicer have been sidelined at Newsmax, and one of
the things Newsmax has done is they brought
in former Fox News host Greta Van Susteren.
Greta Van Susteren had her first episode of the
show yesterday. It was a technical disaster that
is delightful to me. Oh, but, David.
Oh, sir, you're making fun of people.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator, right?
Speaker 1: No, no, no, no, no, no, no. This is
disastrous for America. The fact that Newsmax
has an audience. I'm not saying shut them down.
I'm not saying violate their appeal, let them do
whatever they want, but I want them to fail. And
the technical hilarity that took place yesterday.
Greta Van Susteren tried interviewing Chuck
Grassley, the Republican senator, and it just
wasn't working. Tech disaster after disaster. And
I love it. I love every second of it. I admit it.
Speaker 4: Four more ranking member of the Senate
Judiciary Committee, Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley,
joins us. Good evening, Senator. And it has gotten
absolutely intolerable for the American people.
These prices, gas, food, everything's going
straight up. What can both parties do together?
What is the willingness of both parties to do
together that we can rescue our economy?
Speaker 3:
You'll have to come through
clearer than you have so far. I
couldn't make out what you're saying.
Speaker 4: I'm it. I'm asking you, sir,
that people are suffering so much from gas prices.
Food prices. What can Republicans and Democrats,
what are they willing to do together and what
can they do together to help the economy?
Speaker 3: I'm sorry. It's all muffled with
it. Sounds like you're talking in a cave.
Speaker 1: It sounds like my callers.
Speaker 3: And hear anything you got to
ask me. And I and.
Speaker 4: I. And I totally
understand that, Senator, but this is our first
night on air. And as you can imagine, we have some
apparently some gremlins in the system trying to
get the question off to you. So let me ask you a
question, sort of just generally, sir.
Speaker 1: Is he probably can hear
general questions better than specific
ones. So this is a smart strategy.
Speaker 4: Do you have any sort of thought on
food prices? I know you're from a farm state.
Speaker 3: If you're still trying to interview
me, I can't make it. All right. All right.
Speaker 4: Senator, thank you
very much and will give up.
Speaker 1: Wow. What an explosive interview.
Am I a bad person? Because I love that. I mean,
I'll take the hit if I'm just a bad person because
the show went completely off the rails. I will
accept that, but I absolutely love that. Okay. So
that big shakeup at Newsmax, a but no shortage of
insanity at Newsmax where the guest could hear
the interviewer. Let's talk about that next.